>> MIKE: Hi. My name is Mike and I'm an engineer
on the Android team. I'm going to show you
how you can easily embed web content into
your application. This includes HTML, CSS,
and JavaScript. In addition to displaying
this content, you can also control it from
your application. This is done with an embedded
WebView. Now, the Gmail application that's
included with Android actually uses an embedded
WebView in order to display the contents of
a conversation. We have all the HTML fragments
for each message in the conversation stored
in a database and then we put those together
and display them in a WebView. The WebView
actually looks like it's part of the Gmail
application because it is part of the Gmail
application. For example, if I bring up the
menu, the menu contains all the menu items
you'd expect to see in Gmail and not the kind
of menu items you expect to see in the browser.
There's also two-way communication between
the content that's displayed in the WebView
and the Java application, that's the Gmail
application itself. So, for example, if I
touch on the first item in the list, you can
see that it expands, and the content for that
comes from the JavaScript that's running inside
the WebView, calling out into my Java code
to get the next fragment for HTML and putting
it back into the DOM. You can also have communication
going the other way. So if I star a message,
then my Java code is going to push a change
into the DOM by executing some JavaScript.
And you can see that here. Now, if you want
to use these techniques yourself, we have
some sample code available on the Apps for
Android site that shows how to embed a WebView
and how to have communication in and out of
that WebView from your activity. Using a WebView
is a really good option if you all ready have
a lot of content in HTML and JavaScript, and
it provides a really nice seamless experience
for the user.